most of us drop our bags at the airport
and then forget about me but the
check-in counter is just the start of
their journey the system like Heathrow's
has 30 miles of conveyors globally 3.2
billion bags are checked in annually the
systems don't always run smoothly
airlines lost delayed of helpeth 23
million pieces of luggage last year
if that seems like a lot just be glad to
know that the numbers down 65 percent
since 2007 mostly thanks to some new
tech the revamped process starts with a
better way to track your stuff British
Airways is testing smart tags with
Bluetooth and eating so you can label
your own luggage
Delta's using RFID tags which have chips
that can be tracked even if the barcode
is invisible then it's the same
rollercoaster ride for all of them into
the bowels of the airport this is the
world's busiest Atlanta's
hartsfield-jackson eighty to a hundred
thousand bags a day's shoot through the
eighteen miles of conveyors here many of
them go from plane to plane for
connecting passengers in the most
advanced systems bags are placed into
individual trays so that each one can be
tracked a complex sorting system routes
the bag to the correct place they go
through a security scan and bags that
are checked in early a stacked for
storage and a towering metal structure
by a scuttling robot
then it's down to the loading bay where
they're stacked by hand or by robot arm
into metal cans depending on the plane
those cans can fit in hole or the bags
can be transferred by hand then the
latest apps like this one from American
Airlines let passengers track their bag
every time it's scanned the way you
follow your Amazon packages journey to
your house if it all works like it
should your bag will travel with you all
the way and be waiting for you to pick
up at your destination